so first welcome it's fantastic that all
of you could be here for new president
Saliva's celebration and also that I
could get
celebration by sharing with you guys
some of the work that we've been up to
trying to get the roots well trying to
get it the roots of human irrationality
by turning to our closest living
relatives are you guys getting the
feedback a little bit there is that just
me okay so what I wanted to do today was
to tell you a little bit about some of
the work we've been up to and just to
give you a fast roadmap I'll first try
to answer the question why it makes
sense to study monkeys if what you're
interested in is understanding the way
that humans make decisions if you really
want to know about humans why don't you
just study humans well I'll try to
convince you that turning to our closest
evolutionary relatives is a fantastic
way to get insight into what's going on
in each and every one of your heads out
there even though you're from the human
species not one of these guys up there
after that we'll talk a little bit about
why it makes sense to study
decision-making in monkeys and I'll tell
you about a couple cases where we've
been trying to see whether the monkeys
that we look at are just as irrational
as human beings and we're going to do
that in the context of studying whether
monkeys show framing effects like humans
do and also whether they show some price
biases in the same way that we do and
hopefully if we have time at the end
we'll get into this question of what we
can learn from all this work in monkeys
and how we can become better decision
makers by understanding what primates do
okay but first a question of why it
makes sense to study monkeys well
there's a bunch of different ways to
introduce this but I thought I'd do one
that gives a nice nod to my favorite
webcomic out there which is called XKCD
a wonderful thing to add to your web
browsing if you don't know it but here's
the xkcd version of this insight and
it's not anything specific to this
webcomic it's exactly the kind of thing
that happens when people meet each other
for the first time and they're trying to
figure out how to make sense of what's
going on in some but inside somebody's
head what is this person really like so
imagine you're doing this you're meeting
somebody for the first time you'll
probably do this at some point during
this celebration shake somebody's hand
that you meet and the question is what
do you ask them to get to know them and
this is the part where we really quiz
you like a real audience like what do
you ask what are the things you asked
can yell it out what's your job
where are you from I heard one of those
and that that's the that's the real
answer right so I can give this talk to
a group of yale staff members yell
faculty alumni can give this in high
schools everybody pretty soon comes up
with that answer why do we ask this why
does it matter well it matters where
you're from because that tells me
something about what you're like right
now if I found out that you grew up in
New Haven versus in boston vs and
Shanghai or Paris versus the very same
street that I grew up on it's going to
tell me something about what you're like
isn't a dull where you came from tells
me something about what you're like as
an adult and this is the very same
insight we have when we want to
understand what I think is the biggest
puzzle out there and that's what's going
on inside our heads what controls our
behaviors our motivations our decisions
these are big fundamental problems but
if we want to understand them we're
going to have to give these big
questions the very same insight we give
when we think about getting to know
somebody which is where do all these
fantastic interesting processes come
from in the first place what's the
origin of the way our mind works and the
good news is that this isn't something
that we just get to speculate about this
is something we can empirically asked by
doing different kinds of studies one of
the different populations that gives us
insight into this is to actually study
what's going on inside the minds a very
very young human babies so you can
really get to know what's going on
inside the adult line by studying the
minds of these folks up here and this is
exactly the kind of research that folks
in the psychology department here at
Yale do my colleagues Karen Wynn and
Paul bloom and Frank pile and others do
exactly this where they'll take into the
lab this little guy right here on this
side of the couch try to study how does
he make sense of the world what his
decision processes look like what does
his cognition look like and then we can
see how that cognition changes over time
as we kind of pass over the
developmental couch this can give us
some really rich insight into what's
going on in mind it can tell us how does
the mind gets shaped by things like
human teaching how does the mine get
shaped by things like human language and
human pedagogy and human culture and
schooling this is the kind of insight we
get into taking a developmental approach
our lab does something similar except
our goal is to look not at the
developmental origins but at the
evolutionary origins so in an ideal
world we do something like this we'd
have our own couch except on it it
wouldn't be children of different ages
it would be ancestors that we had over
evolutionary history so we'd kind of
bring this guy into the lab he's like
australopithecines would study heat how
he made sense of the world and what he
knew about the world that we could see
how that changed over evolutionary time
as we get access to things like human
language and human culture and human
teaching this would be a fantastic
empirical approach except it's turned
out to be really hard to recruit
subjects because the various subjects
you want are in fact dead and I can say
this with certainty I was a graduate
student at Harvard I was over there you
know none of these guys are still around
you know even at those other schools
right so so we have to we have to take a
bit of a different approach we have to
use a proxy we can't study our direct
ancestors and what we try to do in our
own lab is to turn to the best proxy we
have which is to ask these very same
questions about our closest living
evolutionary relatives the non-human
primates and so I know some of you are
probably not as familiar with your
clothes primate treat and so I'm going
to give you a very Yale centric version
of the primate order here is your
evolutionary family right here and this
is a slide that you can show only once
or else it starts you know looking weird
when you start showing this year but but
this is the kind of family we're talking
about and it provides a window much like
that developmental couch we can compare
and contrast cognition at the top of
this evolutionary tree and that can give
us insight into how cognition changed
across evolutionary time and we do this
by studying a couple of different
branches at the top of the tree we've
tried to focus mostly on the furthest
branches that we have out there first
these guys here the pro simian primates
the lemurs these are our most distantly
related primate cousins and we've been
able to study them out at a field
reserved down in Myakka City Florida
known as the Lemur Conservation
Foundation the lemurs free range around
a big 30 acre enclosure and we can set
up little enrichment games and cognition
games for the lemurs to play that if one
for the lemurs but they give us insight
into how the lemurs are thinking about
the world so here's a former
undergraduate Jen Barnes trying to get
it what lemurs know about counting so
that's the lemurs we work with we also
work with
a more closely related primate species
these guys here this is the new world
monkey the brown capuchin monkey we're
lucky enough to work with a group of
these guys here at a facility at Yale
the monkeys live in a big social
enclosure with their families they have
lots of fun and it's great for us
because we can get up close and personal
with them and do the kinds of studies
I'm going to tell you about in just a
bit and so these are the capuchin
monkeys that we work with but we're also
lucky enough to work with a group of
monkeys that's even more closely related
to the human species these are the old
world monkeys who branched off from the
very same primate branch that we did is
Old World primates ourselves and the
monkeys that we study are not in the lab
they also live down at a field site
these are rhesus macaques who live down
at the island of Ko Santiago Puerto Rico
it's an island that's just off the coast
of Puerto Rico and it's fun to go to
because it's tropical it's filled with
palm trees you'd be surprised how easy
it is to recruit undergraduates to come
down and do field research with us but
it's fantastic for us because it's home
to about a thousand free-ranging
primates who kind of hang out and do
their monkey thing but we can send
students and staff members down there to
again design studies there with the
monkeys out in the wild to try to see
what they know about the world here's a
former undergraduate Brian Edwards doing
a study to see what rhesus monkeys know
about causality and so this is the big
pictures that we can look across the
different tops of these trees to try to
compare and contrast how cognition looks
like what it looks like in the animal
mind and try to see how that compares
with humans we get insight into things
that are unique to our species like the
role of language the role of human
culture and so on typically when you're
taking this kind of approach it tends to
look like trying to study thinking in
non-human animals to get some insight
into whether the way non-human animals
think is some of the same ways that we
do and in particular we tend to focus on
the kinds of abilities that we're most
proud of in the human species the things
that make us really smart that's what we
want to know the origins of where do
these smart things really come from and
there's been lots and lots of work
exploring just these kind of abilities
in non-human primates for example
there's lots of work taking place down
at the field sites trying to get a sense
of whether or not non-human primates
understand something
about number can they count a small
numbers of objects in the same way that
we do the answer seems to be that they
can but only up to a limited number of
objects so there's interesting
similarities and interesting differences
there there's also some research
interest in trying to see whether or not
non-human animals understand the
physical world in the same way we do
obviously we as humans are using all
kinds of artifacts and tools do other
animals understand the same things that
we do well again we can set up these
physical problems for them little tool
use problems and try to see what they
understand the answer is that even
species that don't use tools themselves
seem to understand something about
simple physics simple cause and effect
and so we can look across all these
different domains to ask this question
do other animals think like we do with
the kind of basic assumption that
there's something special about what it
means to be us there's something that
makes us much smarter than other animals
this is what historically the work in
other primates has looked at but these
days we've been turning this view of
non-human primates on its head rather
than just study whether or not other
animals have all the smart aspects of
cognition that humans do these days
we've been asking whether or not they
have some of the Dumber aspects as well
not sort of man the thing bear but kind
of men the face Palmer and this is the
kind of thing that you learn about human
behavior if you actually hang out with
humans for a lot of time yes it's true
that we have language and human artifact
culture and so on but our species also
does a variety of very dumb things and
dumb in a particular way not just dumb
as and we do kind of crazy things all
the time but done in a systematically
irrational way we do predictable things
that have predictable strategies that
give us less utility less money and less
happiness over time but yet we do it
predictably and even in the face of some
bad consequences this raises the
question of how is it that we're doing
that perhaps we see some seeds of these
same kinds of irrational behaviors in
other primates as well this was the sort
of insight that led us to start trying
to study whether other animals are as
irrational as humans are
and in particular when we started this
approach it was right around the time of
the financial collapse you couldn't
click on the news programs without
seeing something about how dumb people
were with money and all the bad things
we were doing with our economies and we
said well maybe this is a spot to start
maybe this is the spot where we can
start looking at these systematic biases
and other primates and so we decided to
begin studying these kinds of economic
bio seeds all of this work is done in
collaboration with a fantastic former
undergraduate Venkat Lakshman Ryan on
and Keith Ken who is a professor at the
time at yale school of management so we
kind of got together and said watch
where should we start if we're going to
study these economic biases and monkeys
and that led us to trying to see if we
could come up with monkey versions of
some of the same seminal studies that it
so nicely shown different economic
biases in the human species and this is
mostly the work of Danny Kahneman Amos
Tversky and their colleagues all of
which is nicely summarized in Danny's
recent book has new york times
bestseller Thinking Fast and Slow I'm
going to give you one little hint of
these kinds of studies and you'll get a
sense of watching your own irrational
intuitions in action and so here's one
of the studies that Danny presented to
his Princeton undergraduates you bring
undergraduates into a lab and you give
them a particular scenario involving
different financial amounts so you say
this is a great study you come into this
situation and I'm going to award you 10
a one thousand dollars it seems like a
great study particularly for Princeton
undergraduates who tend to be probably a
lot poorer than at least some of you are
one thousand dollars is a big windfall
right but now you get to decide how to
get even more money and here are your
choices you could take a risk to get
more money which case I'm going to flip
a coin if it comes up heads you'll get a
thousand taels you'll get nothing so
that's option number one option number
two is that you could play it safe and
you could just take an extra five
hundred dollars from the experimenter
with certainty and so here's more
audience participation how many go with
taking a risk show of hands how many go
with playing it safe show of hands you
guys are just like Princeton
undergraduates most of them choose to
play it safe and and this makes sense
right Princeton undergraduates poor
probably pretty risk-averse there's
nothing irrational about
this what's irrational is what happens
when you are giving subjects the same
ultimate outcomes but you present it in
a slightly different situation and so
here's that different situation now
undergraduates come in here they're told
now you're going to get two thousand
dollars this seems like an even better
deal except you now have to decide how
to lose some of the money you just got
but you have a choice about how to lose
it you can either lose it in a risky way
I'll flip a coin if it comes up heads
now that's really bad you're going to
lose a thousand dollars tails you lose
nothing or you can choose to lose it in
a very safe way you can just give the
experimenter five hundred dollars back
with certainty now I'm taking a
different dependent measure which is
smirking which I've found is a nice
measure of people's I rationalities
action because if you're like Princeton
undergraduates you might be thinking you
know hang on now this idea of taking a
risk doesn't seem so bad now it seems
like that might be the right move the
one that I might want to go with and
this is exactly what Kahneman and
colleagues found people's risk
preferences shift across these two
framings and most of you who are smiling
are probably also very fast at math
you've computed the fact that these
outcomes are exactly the same across the
two scenarios it's irrational to switch
your preferences so what's going on well
what seems to be going on is that common
and colleagues we're tapping into a
couple different economic biases at work
the first of these is a bias seasonal as
a bias known as reference dependence or
reference point setting and all it means
is just that we tend to as a species pay
a lot more attention than we should to
the status quo to where we are right now
why is that a problem well an economist
would tell you that you should probably
make decisions not in a relative way but
in an absolute way you should think of a
particular decision and ask how is this
going to increase my overall welfare or
my overall utility what's going to be in
my bank account at the end of the day
and so on but that's not how we think of
decisions we tend to think of a decision
as being at a particular status quo and
how that decision will affect how we
move whether it's sort of a gain or a
loss relative to where we are before to
see this sort of thing in action imagine
you
leave here and where to get a parking
ticket new haven parking ticket these
days probably run you about twenty
dollars question is how would you think
of that I bet you wouldn't have seen
that parking ticket and immediately
calculated what your net wealth was
minus that parking ticket you just say
some sort of expletive a parking ticket
this is totally bad this is you thinking
in terms of reference dependence you
have your status quo and the parking
ticket is a negative relative to that
when the parking ticket example
illustrates the second bias that we see
at work which is a phenomenon known as
loss aversion this idea that changes
from the status quo in the positive
direction don't seem nearly as
emotionally big as changes from the
status quo in the negative direction
losses seem to loom a lot larger than
gains and we sometimes work harder to
avoid losses than we do to seek out
equally sized gains it seems like
there's a kink in the way we think about
changes from the status quo and the
scenario you just saw your loss aversion
was probably one of the things that led
you to get more risky in that second
scenario in the second scenario you had
a chance of not getting a loss at all
and that seemed so good that you took on
more risk than you would otherwise have
wanted and this leads to what's known as
this third bias the reflection effect
the fact that we in fact do get more
risk seeking when we're in the red when
we're dealing with losses and that can
lead us to take on intuitions about how
to make decisions that might not fit our
preferences when we're not in the red
these kinds of things happen in these
funny khanam in scenarios but it turns
out you can see them playing out in the
real world in a couple of really
important context one of them is the
puzzle the economists refer to as the
equity premium puzzle this is the fact
that if you look over time over long
horizons stocks always tend to do better
overall than bonds do however if you
look at individual portfolios people
tend to disproportionately invest in
bonds relative to their ultimate value
why is it why are people putting their
money in bonds when stocks will and in
theory yield more money well bonds don't
tend to yield losses as much as stocks
do stocks all your stocks are hopefully
going up and up and up but occasionally
they made if you know periodically into
the red the ideas those dips in the red
looms so large for us that it makes
stocks seem like a bad thing
making us to disproportionately invest
in this thing that's safer but doesn't
yield any of the losses so loss aversion
at work in the stock market we also seem
to see something like loss aversion and
reference dependence in the housing
market one of the problems in the
housing market now is that people are in
some senses pricing their houses a bit
too high and that Hisle houses aren't
selling as quickly as you might think
what's going on there well it seems that
people might be setting a reference
point for the price of their house one
that's not true in the current market
but might be true in their mind if you
think about your own houses and what's
there what they're worth I bet you have
a very very salient reference point
which is what you bought it for what you
find is that people are very loath to
sell houses for under the price they
bought them for which sometimes lead
people to be holding on to the houses
and markets that are losing value the
quickest the setting is reference point
in being a verse to selling at a loss
leads people to sometimes make bad
decisions but my favorite example of
these biases in action happens not in
real financial markets it happens on the
golf course if you are a golfer you know
that your best strategy of performing
well on the golf course is to get
absolutely the lowest score and just
trying to get its lowest score as
possible but each golf hole has a
particular reference point on it it's
the par that's listed on the course
right there par doesn't really matter
your goal is just to get absolutely the
lowest score but it turns out that par
seems to unconsciously effect two
golfers when they're playing when a
golfer has the risk of going above par
which seems like a loss they end up
putting more risk alee and by the same
token when a golfer knows he'll go under
par they tend to put too conservatively
and a group of economists that were in
business school tried to analyze these
kinds of biases as part of the pga tour
and they estimated that across the whole
tour the bias was costing golfers around
1.5 million dollars so real stakes on
the golf course these are deeply
ingrained human biases and the question
is
can we see similar things in a non-human
primate and at first you might think
this is a bit of a crazy question all of
these kinds of biases we've seen have
been in the context of money and
financial decisions but we said you
could we find a method with which we
could ask these booty monkeys that we
work with here at Yale about their own
decision-making processes using
something like money and most of you
guys haven't met my capuchin monkeys I
see some of you guys who worked with the
Commission buddies with those who
haven't met them might not know that
they don't actually use money so this
was a sort of tricky method you know
method number one that we came up with a
scientist quickly you know will use
their money's like no can't use their
money you know back to stage B go to the
drug right well what we decided to do
was to see if we could teach the monkeys
their own kind of currency that we could
use to ask them these financial
questions in an experimental context and
at first we thought this was going to be
really tricky to do but it turned out
that the monkeys picked it up quite
easily we introduced the monkeys to
these little metal discs it was their
own form of currency and we taught them
that they could trade these discs with
human experimenters for food and so
here's what this looked like in one
picture here's made a one of our monkeys
she monkeys all live in a big social
enclosure and they kind of come out by
themselves for testing so none of the
other monkeys will bother them when
they're making choices made it comes in
she gets a little wallet of tokens and
she can hand them over to human
experimenters for food and so here's
just a little video of what this looks
like the bit kind of French New Wave
style but you get the point here's Felix
trading tokens to get his Apple here's
Jill she trades her tokens get some
apple too and so the monkeys picked us
up remarkably quickly very very little
training and they were using this
currency very flexibly with individual
experimenters we said well let's see if
they're understanding this currency in
any way that looks like a real market
why don't we give them the option of
buying some food from two different
experimenters and we'll see if they do
the kinds of rational things that humans
do rationally in the market and maybe
whether they also do the same kinds of
irrational things that humans do too and
so our little monkey market was born
here's how it often worked the monkeys
come in from their social group for
testing they get a little wallet of
tokens and they meet not one but two
different traders who are different
students in the lab who trade different
foods with the monkeys at different
prices and we signal the different
experimenters by giving them different
clothes and they're different
individuals in the lab and so the way
every testing session worked is that the
monkeys come in for testing they get
their little wallet the two traders kind
of move to either side of the monkeys
enclosure they present the food that the
monkey can buy I sir hold it out in a
little dish the monkeys make their
choice which means they hand over one of
the two tokens to the experimenter the
trader gives the monkeys the food and
then this keeps going until the monkey
spend all their money folks always ask
to the monkeys try to like save the
money or wait no they immediately spend
as money as fast as they possibly can um
but just to give you a sense of what the
monkeys do in the market our first
question was whether or not the monkeys
treated these tokens rationally at all
good day for example use the tokens to
spend on experimenters who are offering
better prices for the same good and so
to test that we introduced the monkeys
to two different traders first the monk
you get to meet Kirk Kirk looks like
he's offering a good deal because his
dish has a grape so it's pretty good
deal for the monkeys the monkeys also
get to meet Kirk but if you notice Kirk
is offering a better deal because
although he's up now offering two grapes
and so the question is who does the
monkey shop at with the red experimenter
or the purple guy and so here's a quick
video of what it looks like it's kind of
a monkey I view you can see holly has
her token ready to go sort of
impatiently waiting there she goes her
choices one grape or two and you can see
which one she picks she shops at
experimenter purple and in fact this is
just what we find when we give the
monkeys these choices we see at about
rates of ninety percent the monkeys are
shopping at the guy who's giving them
the best deal it turns out the monkeys
don't do this just for amount of food
they can correctly pay attention to risk
so if a person is risky they'll go with
the guy who overall gives them the best
amount of food they seem to be tracking
the same kinds of things that humans
tend to track pretty well in real
markets and my colleague Keith China's
fond
if you plotted the monkeys data and you
didn't know the data work from a monkey
you just assumed it was from a human we
were shocked at how close the monkeys
were matching real humans in real
markets and so this led us to be able to
ask the question we were really
interested in which is would the monkeys
now behave irrationally in the cases
where humans behave irrationally and we
were able to ask that by putting the
monkeys in exactly the same scenario
that you guys just faced when you are
doing these different scenarios the idea
is we could introduce the monkeys to
experimenters who gave different foods
at different rates somewhere risky some
fell like gains but some felt like
losses to the monkeys and so here's how
we introduced the monkeys to this here's
a case like the first scenario when the
monkeys are getting more than the
experimenters show monkeys meet Vlad and
Wesley and they realize that Vlad and
Wesley do different things they look
like they're starting with one but a
hundred percent of the time Vlad adds an
extra grape for the monkeys to give them
two so he's like safely getting the five
hundred dollars extra the monkeys also
meet Wesley and they realized Wesley's
risky sometimes he only gives the one
grape he shows but sometimes he adds two
grapes to give the monkeys three and so
if you're paying engine is exactly the
same scenarios you got the monkeys get a
choice of a safe gain from Vlad or a
whiskey game from Wesley question is
what do they do well what you find is
that they to tend to play it safe they
tend to shop it flood even though on
average they're getting the same from
both of these guys again that might not
be irrational maybe the monkeys are just
risk averse in the same way that humans
are what happens in the context of the
scenario where the monkeys are getting
less than they expect and so here's how
we introduce that the monkeys get to
meet Alex Alex looks like he's going to
give the monkeys three grapes about a
hundred percent of the time he takes one
away to give the monkeys too and so the
monkeys then get to meet Venkat he also
looks like he's giving three but he's a
risky loss sometimes he takes that away
and sometimes he takes to a way to give
the monkeys only one and again same
thing the same ultimate payoffs as we
saw before and the same average payoffs
across the two experimenters do the
monkeys play it safe with Alex they just
showed us they like playing it safe
before or do they now go with venkat and
what we found robustly is that the
monkeys
this case now tend to shift they now
become more risk seeking just like
humans folks often like to see all the
monkeys data here's just data plotted
across five of the monkeys we tested and
one of the things you see which is me is
that the monkeys are very variable I'm
plotting how often they choose the risky
experiment or so this is some measure of
how much the monkey seek out risk and
you see they kind of very folks always
want to know what's going on with this
monkey here this is Felix our alpha male
he's risk-seeking all the time he's kind
of like the stockbroker monkey I guess
perhaps he's like The Wall Street monkey
but even he despite the variation is
showing this framing effect where he's
getting more risky he's seeking out risk
even more when he's dealing with losses
than when he's dealing with gains and so
what we've found is that not only can we
train the monkeys on this token economy
in a way that they shows at least in
some ways they seem to understand these
tokens in a similar way to the fiat
currency we use but when we train them
on that and ask them about the same
problems that condom and colleagues
tested humans on they're showing the
same kinds of strategies and intuitions
they seem to set reference points they
don't think in terms of the absolute
amount of food they get they see it
relative to what they get from the
experimenter and they seem to like
humans avoid losses to the point that it
makes them seek out risk even more we've
now gone on to test the monkeys on a
couple of other different irrational
biases we've shown that they seem to
overvalue goods that they own so they
seem to like food better when they have
it than food they could potentially get
this is a phenomenon in humans that's
been labeled an endowment effect than
shown in a variety of cases we also seem
to think seem to show that in addition
to this they seem to value these objects
more not just because they have them at
the right time but they have them
immediately but really it seems to be
about actually having the object
potentially a sort of rudimentary
concept of monkey ownership but now I'm
going to switch gears a bit to tell you
about something else we've been working
on recently because we've seen in a
bunch of cases that the monkeys tend to
show biases that suggests in some ways
they're as a
tional as we are but we're also starting
to see hints of cases where the monkeys
look very different from us but this is
different in a way than we typically see
in comparative cognition usually when we
see monkey human differences is the case
that humans have some complex some
relatively smart cognitive ability that
other animals lack but this is a spot
where we're seeing cases where the
monkeys lack a very irrational tendency
that humans had in some sense we're
seeing monkeys being smarter than people
and so we wanted to see which domains we
could see this in and we turn to some
cases that we thought the monkeys might
really show the same biases as we did as
in the case of our biases towards price
we've already shown that the monkeys
understand something about price and so
we wanted to see if they treated price
in the same irrational ways as humans do
and this is all work done with my former
lab manager and undergraduate here Nick
Patrick and a former thesis student Rhea
catapano who graduated a few years ago
and what we wanted to look at was to see
whether or not the monkeys got tripped
up by the price of an object usually
price is a good indicator of an object
quality but not always it turns out
though that we tend to use it as an
indicator of quality even when the price
itself is arbitrary so I could influence
the way you subjectively taste this wine
just by lying to you and telling you
that it was a different price than it
really was and this is what hoga plasmon
and colleagues did with subjects they
presented subjects with different kinds
of wine each kind of wine is labeled in
a color here and told subjects different
prices for those different wines so they
said here sip this wine this is a five
dollar wine here's sip this wine this is
a 42 five dollar one but it was exactly
the same one and they had subjects rate
on a on a scale how much they liked them
and what they found is that subjects
tend to rate wines that are just said to
be more expensive as more tasty as
though I'm influencing your subjective
preference for the wine by lying to you
and telling you the price is different
the neat thing though is it wasn't just
true in their Likert scale ratings
plasmid and colleagues are
neuroscientists who also measure in
reward regions of the brain how subjects
are perceiving these events as they
drink the wine they're not reading them
they're really tasting them knowing the
different prices and what they found was
that if you look at a signal in the
orbital frontal cortex that's tend to
thought to signal something about
subjective value or award what you find
is that the very same line will activate
this region more if you think it's
ninety dollars then if you think it's
ten dollars really at the level of your
reward areas you're falling for this
price information and so the question is
given that the monkeys know something
about this this token economy given that
we've showed that they understand
something about price in these markets
do they fall for this too if we teach
them that a particular good is more
expensive will they also end up liking
that more and so this was what we
embarked upon first we wanted to make
sure again that the monkeys kind of
understood price in their market and the
way we teach the monkey is the price of
a good is to vary how much of the good
they get so the monkeys never pay us
more tokens the the nominal price is
always a single token but we can vary
how much food the monkeys get so if the
monkeys pay a token and get a huge huge
piece of food that food is really cheap
if they pay a single token and get a
really really tiny piece of food then
that food would be really expensive it's
kind of like if you you know if you go
into the store you could get you know
hirsch a huge thing of Hershey's
chocolate for you know a couple dollars
but the you know nice lindt chocolates
you only get a teeny tiny piece of it
for the same price and so we did the
same sort of chocolate study with the
monkeys we introduce them to new
experimenters this time the monkeys were
getting foods that we were considering
different brands there were different
pieces of cereal that the monkeys like a
lot and they meet the two experimenters
who each of the brands cost the same
amount in the sense that they're each
getting a single piece of cereal from
the experimenters from each brand so
McGee's get a choice of clover brand
versus the moon brand they make their
choice it's about equal but then we make
one of the goods go on sale and so now
the moon brand has gone on sale the
monkeys get three times as much stuff
there and the question is do the monkeys
as they should rationally shift their
purchasing more to the moon they sort of
shift their budget set to buy more of
the moon stuff and so here's what we
find if we're plotting how often the
monkeys pick the cheap guy and the cheap
good versus the expense of good here's
what happens in the
case where both of the prices are equal
on plotting how often they pick the
cheap good basically what we find is
they they pick evenly however as soon as
you make the cheap good go on sale
pretty much all the monkeys shop at the
cheap experiment are really robustly
they seem to get price in the way we're
teaching it to them question is are we
affecting their preferences for these
different brands and the way we ask that
was to give the monkeys a slightly
different shift in the way we presented
them with the food now the monkeys meet
these different traders and they're
paying the traders for the food they
meet this new horse shoe brand which is
pretty expensive they only get a tiny
piece of cereal versus the moon brand
they get three they trade with each of
these guys in their market separately
and then we just allow the monkeys to
eat from these different brands
themselves so they come in they don't
have their typical wallet but they just
get to sample whichever foods they want
and the idea if you imagine is if you
know the price of different wines you
might want to try a five-hundred-dollar
wine but given your personal finances
you might may not be able to drink it
every day however if you come to the
Yale reception at the inauguration and
at Peter's table is that five hundred
dollar one versus a five dollar wine and
you don't have to pay which one are you
going to go for and so this is what we
were offering the monkeys we're giving
them a choice for free between the good
that was cheap versus the good that was
expensive and the question is do they
like us go for the expensive one and so
I'll plot in yellow how often the
monkeys pick cheap and in brown hof and
they pick expensive and this was a
pretty robust finding where the monkeys
were perfectly at chance they just
didn't care they didn't in this case go
for the expensive one even though they
just showed us they knew something about
what it meant for this good to be
expensive we've now done this a couple
different ways using these kind of cheap
and expensive brands we've presented the
monkeys with cheap and expensive novel
food so the foods were new to them and
we've even tried out cheap and
inexpensive familiar foods in case
something about the novelty was messing
with them in all of these cases what we
found is just no effect even though
humans robustly seem to pick up on a
price as an indicator of value we're not
seeing this in
case of the monkeys and this was the
first spot whether we were finding a
difference in the Iraq in these
irrational biases and humans and monkeys
in the first case where we were finding
the monkeys were in fact a lot smarter
than humans seem to be and so the
question is why are we seeing the
difference here why is it that the
monkey show loss aversion a reference
dependence but they're not tripped up by
price in the same way that humans are
even though we've shown that they
understand price as defined by economics
are as defined by economists well what
idea we thought is that the market we've
set up for the monkeys differs of course
in a lot of ways from the market that we
see in humans but one way in particular
is that their goods and services the
prices of those things are determined by
the experimenters determined by our
whims of which particular question we're
studying at any one time it's not like a
real human market where prices are
determined in theory by supply and
demand so maybe one of the reasons
they're not showing the effect is that
they seem to not be present in markets
where price is an honest indicator
that's one possibility but we worried
that the human price was telling us
something different that it's not that
we're in markets where we learn
something about the objective price of
these real goods the real price is based
on supply and demand maybe what are real
markets give us is they that price tells
us something about how much other people
in our market want to buy it maybe it
gives us a cue about what other people
are thinking and what other people know
and what other people desire and you can
see this a little bit if you think about
the kinds of luxury goods we see in our
society today this is just a picture of
the apple store in New York the day
before the iphone 5 was going to be
coming out this is the day before so 24
hours before all these able-bodied
youths are sitting outside the iphone
store waiting to get this new luxury
good you know why is the iphone 5 really
good I'm not really sure but all these
people seem to think the iphone 5s
really good maybe it's really good and
the idea is that this might be what the
price information is doing in the
context of human cognition maybe pricing
information is telling us something
about what the other people know and
what the other people want and this
might be one of the reasons we pay
attention to it more than other primates
this is apparently the first guy to come
this isn't the iphone 5 this is the
first iphone when people were waiting in
line for many more than 24 hours he came
out and you know he was cheered for you
know obviously this is a good that
everybody wants I don't even know what
the iphone is but I should like it
because everybody else likes it and so
this led us to question what else we
know in the literature about primates
about the extent to which other animals
pick up on what other individuals want
and what other individuals like and do
they seem to do that in some cases more
irrationally than humans do well there's
an interesting literature on this
looking not necessarily our preferences
but about understanding of different
things about cases of pedagogy and wheat
which teachers you listen to in which
teachers you don't this work was
originally done by Vicki Horner and her
colleagues and it tests and compares
chimpanzees and human children on a
different puzzle box solving tasks and
here's how the puzzle box passed both
kids and chimpanzees are presented with
this weird box that has some food in it
and their task is to figure out how to
open it and it's pretty weird and
complicated looking you wouldn't
normally be able to figure out how to
open it but the good news is that you
have a human demonstrator so this is
what the box looks like it's got a
couple of affordances like this door and
the sting on top you don't know what to
do that you to watch somebody solve it
and so here's Vicki solving it for the
chimpanzees this is with chimpanzees who
live in a sanctuary in Gamla Island and
see she's showing the chimpanzees how to
open it I guess you have to take those
little rods out at the top using this
tool you see the chimú watching it you
have to stick the tool inside and then
only then you can open it and then get
the food out so chimpanzees see that and
the question is do they learn from what
they saw the human do and the answer is
you'll see is that yes they do when they
don't know how to solve something
they're perfectly happy using what
somebody else knows to figure this out
and so they do the thing that Vicki did
opening the thing on the top with tool
and then they use the tool to open the
door and so that's what happens in
chimpanzees and the neat thing is that
the very same thing seems to happen in
human children if they watch a human
adult solve this puzzle box they're very
capable of than solving the puzzle box
themselves that's Derek Lyons who is a
grad student here at Yale who did some
of this work as well so kids totally
figure this out and watch what somebody
else knows but none of this is a ration
of course because they don't know how
the box works it's a perfectly good
thing to do to pay attention to what
somebody else knows and then follow that
and do it yourself the question though
is what if it wasn't the obvious way to
solve the box like here you don't know
how the box worked so it seems totally
reasonable to take this thing out and
use this thick to try to open it and do
this whole thing before you open the
door but what if what if the box was
transparent and what if you could see
just because you're pretty smart
causally that there was a false top at
the top of the box and that there's
nothing in the false top so this whole
part about taking the tool out and then
kind of sticking the tool into the box
like this is pretty stupid because it's
not doing anything it's just going into
air but you would probably be able to
figure that out on your own but what if
you saw a well-intentioned demonstrator
who is doing it the wrong way what if
you saw somebody do the bad part would
you copy them and would chimpanzees and
children do this as well and this is
what Vicki Horner asked second box that
I show the chimpanzees is this one and
it's identical to the opaque box except
that it's made out of material which is
season only now is it obvious that the
tapping and poking don't achieve a thing
the box has a full ceiling
okay so you're a chimpanzee you just
watched Vicki do this you're physically
capable of realizing about the false top
the question is do you follow Vicki or
do you just sort it out on your own
here's what you meant to do the chims
cut to the chase they skipped the
needless steps for the Apes it is all
about the treat okay so pretty rational
chimpanzees they can figure out on their
own how to solve it they don't copy you
at all question though you're already
laughing what about human children well
youryour laughter indicates you might
have more insight into human children
than you think cuz here's what children
do we found something quite surprising
the children were predisposed to copy
even when it meant that they were doing
something that was really rather silly
so this seems a little like the chimps
are outsmarting the kids in this
particular study there he is you got em
out and so the claim here is that may be
what's going on in the case of some of
these pricing effects and other effects
is that we are very prone to follow what
other social agents are telling us even
when those other social agents are doing
something that's really rather silly or
really particularly stupid and now this
was the earliest version of these
findings by Vicki Horner and Andy white
and in colleagues and these are now been
replicated in a couple I think really
important ways what is the question to
look at is this just American kids who
are trained you know my Tiger moms uh
follow what moms do and so on is this
true in general of different populations
particularly ones where you don't have
lots of complex artifacts room and to
test that researchers went and tried the
same sort of tests with the Cong in
Africa a modern-day hunter-gatherer
population and what you find is that
children of the same age in these
hunter-gatherer populations show this
same imitation effect in other words
they over imitate what they see people
do you
than when they would have known how to
do it themselves before so it's not just
something weird about American kids
following what moms tell them or a kids
who are prone to dealing with all these
complex artifacts seems to be true at
least across the societies that have
been tested so far another thing that
Derek lions and Frank I'll in this
department here at Yale worried about
was maybe this was just the case that
the child thinks he's supposed to be
following what the experimenter says of
course the experimenter standing there
he's just showing him how to do it maybe
it's not that it's really messing with
what the kid understands about the
object maybe it's just the kid thinks
he's supposed to do this and so Derek
design along and really clever series of
studies to try to convince the child
when he's being tested that in fact the
experimenters not watching you at all
the experiments completely over and it's
a terrible emergency and you must open
the box as quickly as humanly possible
so here's how Derek did it i'll show you
another short video of this here's Derek
just demonstrating this other weird
object so that's the thing you need to
do to open the box and here's an
irrelevant thing that's just to stick
this stuck into the middle of this thing
touching nothing Derek takes that out
opens it and finds the good so this is
Derek he teaches this thing and then the
experiment goes on the child is
presented with a bunch of other things
that are supposed to be the real
experiment and Derek says oh you'd agree
experiments over and now you're getting
your prize and so here's this happening
he's saying you did such a good job and
so Dina comes in and says this is for
the next kid and so it's not even for
her anymore next kid's going to come in
so is it just wait here one second guys
that for right now
okay right back so Derek says I'm going
to write down your answers goes to leave
and then he says oh and here's the
emergency what so there's another kid
coming in so I'm kind of in a hurry but
I got it right down her stuff but last
time when Dina brought these toys back
in she forgot to put a turtle's back
into toys so when the kid came to play
there were no turtles in Italy really
spoiled the game so while I'm in the
other room writing down your answers
could you check and make sure there's
Turtles in here for me did you even
check both objects okay so incompetent
research assistant there might not be
Turtles the other kids here can you open
it as quickly as possible and you see
she's kind of trying to do this quickly
she's even doing this sort of tapping
that Derek does to get the child
attention Yanks out the thing and does
it open so chic even follows Derek when
it's an emergency no one's there to
watch her she has to do it really fast
usually she's taking this very seriously
but basically what Derek's found is that
in fact it does seem like watching an
intentional experimenter changes the way
the child thinks about this particular
game Derek Derek quizzes the child later
to ask how does the box causally work
and all the kids that saw him do the
irrelevant action come up with a causal
story a physical story about why you
need to take these objects out they
develop these rich ideas about the
physical world just based on what
intentional humans do even when a child
of that age could have told you that the
Box didn't work like that a few minutes
earlier there it claims that it causally
overrides and physical knowledge that
children have that we get from watching
other social agents and I think this is
one of the powerful mechanisms we have
perhaps uniquely as a human mind we get
to learn from all the smart things that
other people do but it might be that our
minds aren't fit with a great filter for
figuring out which of those things are
smart and which of those things are done
it's a powerful mechanism if we're
surrounded by people who are doing
really nice things but it's a bad thing
to do if you're surrounded by people who
are doing silly things and so with that
I'm going to sort of jump to some
conclusions really what does this all
mean we'll go back to our
Yale centric tree of the primate order I
think of what I've told you is that at
least some of the kinds of irrational
things we see humans doing on a regular
basis in real markets with their stocks
and on the golf course we seem to see
hints of across the primate tree
particularly this guy right here the
brown capuchin monkey we see that these
guys also make these kinds of same
errors suggesting that perhaps some of
the strategies we see humans using might
be evolutionarily old they might have
emerged back at our common ancestor
between President salivate and the
capuchin monkey way back here and this
would put us at about 35 million years
ago these might be strategies that seem
irrational and current markets but they
might be evolutionarily really really
old at the same time we're finding that
certain kinds of irrational things
people do we seem to do alone so they're
here on the third president salad of a
branch and they might not be there on
similar branches and other species this
suggests that some of these kinds of
strategies like conforming and copying
an experimenter who's doing something
dumb might be evolutionarily new but it
raises the question of what some of
these strategies might be for in a good
sense what are they giving us to conform
and pay attention and obey interesting
question there but rather than focus on
that I wanted to end really quickly
today with the kinds of tips I think
we're getting from monkeys you know what
can we actually learn about our own
decisions based on what I've told you
well I think a couple of important
things particularly from the first part
of the talk where we've seen such rich
similarities the first thing I think the
monkeys teach us is that we need to take
these reference points really seriously
and the reason is that they seem to be
evolutionarily really old we seem to pay
attention to them for a long time what
other human strategies are
evolutionarily old well they tend to be
things that are built in pretty severely
so imagine at the reception you see
objects that look like this you might be
watching your weight or your cholesterol
you might rationally think you need to
avoid those things but if there's part
of you that reacts to them in a very old
evolutionary way this is rich sugar-rich
calories and
to seek that thing out the claim is that
reference points might work in exactly
the same way it's also evolutionarily
old and it might also be just as hard to
override so if you happen hopefully none
of your portfolio look like this but if
you happen to see a portfolio that kind
of went down and down and down the claim
is that it's going to be really tricky
to respond to that rationally speaking
it might work a lot like the cupcake
where you're going to have automatic
responses to these that might be tricky
to overcome and I think that means we
need to use reference points wisely in
our own lives and pay attention to when
they're there because it's true what
other people are using these reference
points against us how many times have
you seen an advertisement that's giving
you information not about the current
price but about something that's
completely irrelevant like what the
object used to be worth before the claim
is that you can't helped Cena except
like seeing it like a cupcake you're
like wow this thing has to be a great
value it's really cheap now right you
have to pay attention when people are
using these reference points against you
the claim is that it's going to be hard
for you to override your automatic
reaction to what they look like so
that's sort of point number one I think
point number two is that we should think
about the fact that reference points are
there I think reference points give rise
to one of the funniest things about
human cognition which is that we don't
have great predictions about what's
going to make us happy in the future
we're good at what's going to predict
we're predicting what's going to make us
happy in the moment but those kinds of
choices we make don't have the long-term
happiness impact we think a part of the
reason is due to reference points when I
first got my own iphone i thought the
iphone was going to change my life every
day that i was as happy as that guy who
walked at an iphone that moment of
happiness then i thought when i woke up
on a thursday many years later i would
have that same happiness but of course
that's not true you know we can still
pretty good now a year later it's just
kind of the old iphone and I want to get
a new one right but this doesn't
necessarily enter your calculations when
you're thinking about buying new gadgets
you think a whole a new iPad that would
make me so happy a whole new you know
whatever the next thing is right well
why doesn't it well it doesn't in part
because of reference point settings that
when i was first buying the iphone i was
a person without one so getting it was
this big game but the next day I'm
new status quo I'm just an iphone honor
it's just a regular thing in my life and
stuff that we buy particularly things
tends to have this trait we just becomes
a new reference point and we tend to not
take that into account and this sir
falls under the line of what
psychologists have often referred to as
this concept of the hedonic treadmill
this tendency to sort of set new
reference points means that we often go
back to asset level of happiness even
when we get these good gains and these
good losses in our lives because we
return to the set point these things
that change don't have that much of an
impact or at least as much of an impact
as we'd like to think and a psychologist
at Harvard and Gilbert has talked a lot
about this in his work on effective
forecasting he had what I think is this
fantastic quote in his book stumbling on
happiness that wonderful things are
especially wonderful the first time they
happen but they're wonderful in this
kind of wings with repetition you know
the first time your partner says I love
you or the first time your child says
mommy this is like the best moment ever
but you know time 2046 you know it's
wonderfulness has waned this is the
problem with us being a reference point
setting species is that the stuff that
we love now we're just going to get used
to it's just going to be a status quo
and so the question remains how do we
get off the treadmill well the good news
is that we're seeing lots of ways that
we can split our reference points up
break up the status quo so we don't do
this one is just to increase the kinds
of variety in your life by doing the
same old thing over and over again this
fifth cone of chocolate ice cream is
going to see him exactly like the first
one it's just going to be your reference
point no extra happiness bang for your
buck the way to break it up of course is
to include variety know if you switched
it up a bit by the time you get to the
fifth ice cream cone it would now seem
something like something new and
exciting you get extra chocolate nice
bang for your buck by having switched it
up this is what variety does and it's
also what timing different events does
pretty well if you were to have you kind
of know implicitly the two ice cream
cones within 14 seconds of each other
you're going to get this diminishing
returns and part because you've set this
reference point you're just an ice cream
cone eater right now but you know if you
wait a little bit of a while from time
one of awesome thing to time to you can
get off the hedonic treadmill
I think again this is something the
human species implicitly knows if you
take some of the best events we
experience in our lives things like
weddings or Yale reunions or
presidential inaugurations for example
we tend to do the best best best things
very very infrequently and if you think
about it it makes sense you know this
presidential inauguration would be a
fantastic weekend but if we had to come
out and do this every single Friday and
it would wane in comparison with how
awesome it was and so we can use timing
to pop off the treadmill but the third
thing we can use to pop off the
treadmill is to remember that when we're
spending to increase happiness we should
avoid spending on things and I'm
underlining buying the right things here
because things tend to have this quality
that they don't really work well for a
reference point setting species all the
kinds of new gadgets you might want to
buy at the moment of purchase will be a
gain for you but as soon as you own them
you'll just be an owner you'll get way
less happiness bang for your buck with
them and it turns out this psychologists
have learned that this seems to be true
if you're looking at the happiness boost
you get four things over time things
Wayne but spending your money on things
that won't last things like experiences
things like going on a vacation going to
a concert or going to the movies those
things don't have time to become your
new reference point it would be nice if
the vacation could just become the new
reference point you were just you know
on the cruise like Laurie but that
doesn't happen unless you're very very
wealthy and so the beauty of spending
your money on experiences you don't have
to worry about the reference point
problem you can avoid this 35 million
year old glitch and our happiness
technology and just enjoy the things you
give the same sort of thing can be said
by spending your money on things but not
things that you yourself will get things
that other people will get and this
mirrors work by people like Mike Morken
night Norton at Harvard and Liz Dunn ubc
who are finding that buying things for
other people and donating in general
seems to have more happiness bang for
our buck than spending the money on
ourselves and this is just the little
aya aya folks are like putting their
thumbs up take that away
so the whole point of this has been just
say that one way to deal with the fact
that we have these irrational ities
stuck around for 35 million years is to
try to use our own biases to our
advantage and if you need other hints
for how to do this I highly recommend
this recent book by sailor and Sunstein
on nudges how can you actually improve
your decisions not by overriding your
biases but kind of using them to hear
and so with that I will kind of end
quickly I want to sort of convince you
or I hope I've convinced you that
studying the evolution of cognition is
important and also studying the done
seer parts of our cognition is important
and that looking across the evolutionary
history of these things is very is very
critical and so with that I will give
you my thank you slide this is my thank
you slide because I'm this monkey here
who's not doing anything they're just
kind of relaxing these are all my
students and funders who did all the
hard work here's all the folks you've
heard about before and the folks that
paid for it and I kind of wanted to end
with a bit of a shout out to my
colleague Peter salivate this is Peter
when I met him when he was chair of the
department when I got hired by the
psychology department here and Peter was
fantastically useful in bringing a
psychologist here and convincing the
University that it would be worth giving
this really young random grad student
psychologist a very very expensive
primary facility on campus and he did a
fantastic thing to advance the science
by helping me do that and he's been such
a wonderful wonderful colleague I can't
imagine what fantastic things he'll do
for the University and just to highlight
the kinds of awesome things Peter did as
Provost I'm excited to announce and I'm
happy to announce here at Peter
celebration that we will soon be opening
yells first canine cognition Center this
will be a new center where we're looking
at the evolution of the mind not by
studying other primates but by studying
man's best friend we are already doing
some work at different doggy daycare
centers in the New Haven area this is my
postdoc Ellen furlong showing some of
the studies we do but I'm excited to
report that we will be open
cognition Center for dogs at Yale
University if any of you in the room
have companion animals little furry
friends who like science we would love
to recruit them so please come see me
afterwards we're hoping we just came
back to see the new flooring on the
facility it's going to be very very cute
for your canine friends and we're going
to be hoping to open sometime in
November and so I hope you will share
not just in the fun of science but
you'll have your pets share in the fun
or science too and with that I will
really really end thank you for your
time
you